We have organized the materials in this course, into eight major units,
this chart illustrates those eight units. So starting from the top left,
the first unit has to do with Fundamentals of presentation and recent, Panning,
Common Sense Reasoning. Analogical Reasoning, Metacognition that we just talked
a little about, Design & Creativity, Visuospatial Reasoning, and Learning.
Now let's look at each of these circles, one at a time. So in the first part,
dealing with the Fundamentals of this course. We'll be dealing with certain,
knowledge representations, and reasoning strategies. Two of the major
knowledge representations that we'll discuss in the first part of this course,
are called Semantic Networks, and Production Systems. Three of
the reasoning strategies, are called Generate and Test, Means-End Analysis, and
Problem Reduction. Note that, the arrows here imply an ordering.
There is an ordering. In that, when we are discussing our Production Systems,
we might allude to things that we are discussing in the Semantic Networks.
Similarly, when we discuss Means-End Analysis, we might allude to things that we
are discussing in Generate and Test. However. It is important to note also,
that these three methods are completely independent from each other.
It's just that we are going to discuss them, in the order shown here.
Similarly these two knowledge representations, are independent from each other.
It's simply that in this course, we'll discuss them in this order.
So the second major unit in this course. Pertains to Planning. Planning is
kind of problem solving activity whose goal is to come up with plans, for
achieving one or more goals. Before we discuss Planning, we'll
discuss Logic as a knowledge representation. This knowledge representation,
will then enable us to discuss Planning in a systematic way. The third
major unit in this course is common sense reasoning. Common Sense Reasoning,
pertains to reasoning about every day situations in the world. As an example,
I may give you the input, John gave the book to Mary. Note the input,
does not specify who has the book at the end. But, you can draw that
inference easily. That is an example of Common Sense Reasoning. In our course,
we'll discuss both knowledge representations like frames, as well as methods for
doing Common Sense Reasoning. As we discussed earlier,
when we were talking about the architecture of a cognitive system,
Learning is a fundamental process within deliberation. And therefore, we will be
visiting the issue of Learning many, many times throughout this course. However,
we also have a unit on Learning, which has several topics in it. There are other
topics in Learning, that do not show up in this particular. Circle here but
are distributed throughout the course. Another major unit in our course is
Analogical Reasoning. Analogical Reasoning is, reasoning about novel problems or
novel situations, but, analogic to what we know about familiar problems, or
familiar situations. As I mentioned earlier, Learning is distributed throughout
this course. Therefore Learning comes here in Analogical Reasoning also. In fact
Learning by recording cases appeared in the Learning topic as well as here, and
you can see explanation based Learning occurring here. Visuospatial Reasoning is
another major unit in our course. Visuospatial Reasoning pertains to
reasoning with visual knowledge. As an example, I might draw a diagram and
reason with the diagram. That's an example of Visualspatial Reasoning.
In the context of Visualspatial Reasoning, we're talking both about
Constraint Propagation, and using that to do Visualspatial Reasoning. Design
& Creativity is the next topic in our course. We want to build AI systems,
that can deal with novel situations, and come up with creative solutions.
Design is an example of a complex task which can be very, very creative,
where we are discussing a range of topics in the context of Design & Creativity.
So in the next topic in our courses Metacognition,
we have already come across a notion in Metacognition,
when we were talking about the architecture of the cognize system. Metacognition
pertains to thinking about thinking. And we'll discuss a range of topics and
then, we will end the course by talking about Ethics in Artificial Intelligence.
This figure illustrates all the eight major units once again, as well as
the topics within each major unit. I hope this will give you mental map
of the organization of the course as a whole. In preparing this course, we came
up with a ordering of the topics, which will interleave many of these topics. So
we will not do the entire first unit, before we go to the entire second unit and
so on. Instead, we will do some parts of first unit, then go to
some other part that follows conceptually from it, and so there will be
some interleaving among these topics. And one aspect of the personalization is,
that you are welcome to go through these topics in your own chosen order.
You don't have to stay, with the kind of order that we'll be using.
This is an exciting agenda. I hope you are as excited as I am.
There are very few, opportunities where we can talk about exotic topics,
like Analogical Reasoning, and Creativity, and Metacognition. And,
in this particular course, we'll talk about all of them together.